how does a man really kind of connect to
what's needed in the moment well first
of all I want to say that being in touch
with your emotions is not feminine but
that's one of the big big dogmatic
misunderstandings right in every human
being there is both masculine and
feminine and both masculine and feminine
has to be present to be with each other
right it's just that feminine presence
still requires that she's able to keep
eye contact and be with you and feel you
I would say presence both on the
masculine and the feminine would be
considered what you do so that you can
feel for somebody fully it looks certain
ways in a man's body or in a masculine
being both is true and it looks certain
ways in a feminine being or in a woman's
body and you know that you could be a
masculine essence in a woman's body and
the other way around but there are
certain qualities that come with having
a woman's body and there's certain
qualities that come with a man's body
and then there's masculine and feminine
within that so keeping eye contact being
able to feel another human that's true
for both masculine and feminine and for
both men and women but for instance
having emotions or feeling emotions is
also not masculine and feminine that's
just human how it expresses has
different ways so the masculine in human
is capable of bracketing the emotions
appropriate to the course of action and
in proceed with a certain clarity while
that same humans feminine when it's
allowed to play full out will take these
emotions and let them swirl however they
need to be swirled and will allow for
these emotions to guide the action so we
can do both both I can right now sit
with you
regardless of what the hell's going on
out there and in me
because in this particular moment I am
choosing to stay focused on our
interview so that would be my masculine
and my very very strong emotions or
being bracketed for the sake of getting
things done if you were my man and we
are not in an interview or if my husband
comes in here after we're done with with
this interview I might let my emotions
flow however they want to because that's
what's called for but getting in touch
with emotions is not masculine or
feminine it's just what human beings
have to do to become full human beings